hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
before we talk about this amazing
collaboration i just want to say
it's so meaningful that you've you know
been outspoken about your struggles with
infertility
because so many women go through it and
they don't have
really anyone to look to so i'm so
appreciative of that
i know you shared it on your instagram
so have you see
like received amazing responses from
other women
you know it's a really incredible
experience
and it really like just goes to show you
like what it means to be open and even
just start the conversation because
whether it was me talking about my
issues with depression and ptsd
people came out and like were like i
felt really alone and they shared their
stories with me and then
i it's it's always like oh my gosh like
should i be
sharing this and then even people that
were my friends
that like i had no idea that they had
struggled or they have
had losses like the fact that it's so
common
and that nobody talks about it is so
crazy to me because it's a big thing you
know
whether it's infertility or whether it's
losses
i mean it's really insane and
it's really sad and lonely so i'm i'm
glad
it like makes me kind of proud of myself
yeah i was like well
it's like well you know i guess that big
voice in my head is like well why do you
want to talk about something sad when
it's something happy
but like because they go hand in hand
and it's also really important for me to
to show people that it does happen when
you know sometimes you have to make some
changes in your life i had to leave la
and
i had to like change a lot of things
about my life and i had to work with the
doctor
and it happened you know but it's it's
totally possible
and it's something that people should
talk about because it really takes some
of the
i don't know it just it just helps
weight the weight yeah the weight
perfect yeah absolutely how are you
feeling today
i'm feeling good i'm feeling really good
um
it's exciting to like you know i i'm
doing a couple interviews today and it's
exciting to
to talk about the pregnancy and
everything especially because
your your like society tells you to like
be so quiet about it for
like three months and that's a long time
i can't keep a secret for
a day so it's um it's really
just like very uplifting to talk about
it and to have it be celebrated
uh so it's beautiful i feel like i'm
really
like get really really sick in this
pregnancy um
so but i'm always just like it's okay
like
it's okay it's it's the baby i'm fine i
love it i love it thank you
do you get like pregnancy cravings are
there things that you're just like oh
again
i can't believe i eat it yeah i i don't
really want any meat
um i i really i eat a lot of fruit
and then when i'm eating something salty
i like crave ketchup
which is really weird because i'm not
like a huge ketchup
and like mustard person but i'm like
just pour it in my mouth
so how long was it between you know
filming the video for drunk
and finding out you're expecting a baby
therefore won't be drunk anytime soon
um well
you know what i we didn't we didn't like
officially
it's hard because oh my god i feel like
i'm gonna get gonna get in trouble
i i get drunk when i film the music
video but i was
pregnant i was pregnant and that that
cigarette they gave me was not a real
cigarette so i can't get in trouble
no no trouble it's a movie but i was
already pregnant we found out we were
pregnant on christmas so
so i was pregnant when we did the video
um i didn't drink and those beers they
were sodas
so they kept it really safe yes of
course they're gonna keep it safe for
you
yeah but i i will say like when i first
started telling
i told my manager that i was pregnant at
the drunk video shoot she was like this
like
oh my gosh we're gonna have to rewrap
this whole tour
she was like oh my gosh like we would be
filming a music video
for a song called drunk and like you're
showing me your baby bump so
it was i mean it's just exciting and
it's so exciting
oh i i just get so nervous i'm like oh
my god like am i gonna get trouble but
no i'm following all the rules and i'm
doing really
good yeah but um yeah if anybody sees me
drinking anything like it's sparkling
water
we we trust you girl we're not i swear
i swear it's we believe you it's all
good no worries at all
um what i love about this song is it's
literally the anthem when
quarantine is over when things are
opening up more and they are they are
slowly opening up i'm in la
i feel like this is the song like i
don't want to go home no one's going to
want to go home
they're just going to have a good time
like besides me being pregnant right now
like this timing couldn't have been
perfect like more perfect because
if you think yeah like what are people
going to want to be chanting like
they're not going to want to hear
closing time
you know what i'm saying they're going
to want to hear like i'm drunk i don't
want to go home
i've been there for over a year don't
send me back there i'm staying out
i'm outside yeah i'm outside i'm seeing
people it's really nice to see people
um so that that was like you know
when i started making my second record i
was like what am i putting out into the
world like
what are people gonna how are people
gonna receive it what does it mean and
it's like
you know what this is a really good time
like to put this out because
i really do feel i really feel like by
summer time
and this is a pretty summertime song you
know yeah um
i feel like a lot of things are going to
be really
open and i feel like this is a great
summer anthem of like people are going
to want to celebrate that they can see
their friends again that they can
leave their house and honestly just the
fact of like
i can feel like now that everyone's
getting you know so many vaccinations it
is it is going to make it safer um and
so
i think the fact that people can feel
safe and feel free
hopefully in the future again is there's
so much power in that because
i know that i haven't felt safe i
haven't felt free
and this whole song is about it's
literally about being
free and having fun so i think it's a
good time for it and i think that people
need it
you know yeah absolutely i know that you
actually met miranda lambert
at one of your shows yeah so on a scale
of one to 10 if you were to go back to
that moment
how surprised were you that she showed
up
like a 12 i mean because she's such a
superstar
and um she came with dirks and and so
i had like a twofer of like two of the
biggest stars in country music
wanting to come to my concert and so i
was like
and i just like was super flabbergasted
but then
you know just like with dirks like you
meet them
and they're the most down-to-earth the
most wonderful lovely
just great human beings and um
it was just like kind of an instant
friendship and so
when when it came down to
a tour and miranda asked me to come on
tour with her
i was like that's badass yeah i'm going
and
um and then that's kind of like how we
started to get close just because
she's the coolest and i would i would
run to the side stage
to hear her say tequila tequila does
every night
i mean it's she's just so wonderful
she's such a magnetic performer and
she's just as magnetic
off stage as she is on stage and so i
feel like it's
really been a dream come true to to get
to sing a song with her
and um i think she's been having a lot
of fun with it too
so that's really the only thing that i
cared about you know
like let's make sure this is fun for
everybody um
and you know because this is also it's
it's sort of outside of her comfort zone
too because she's
such a country powerhouse you know and i
guess you know this kind of guy
i know it's being played on on pop radio
which is
so cool that this is crossing you know
that this can be played on so many
formats right now like country
uh pop and alternative which is just
it's just awesome
it's it's another one of those like
we didn't know we don't know what's
going to go on but like
it's kind of fun right like that's how
x's and o's was it's like
that's kind of fun like we don't know
what's going to happen let's just put it
out
we'll see so i remember when my nose
came out and i was at the cottage and i
remember hearing it for the first time
we had the radio on
i was addicted to it i was like i need
to hear it again
it's one of those your voice it's just
one of those voices that you just
you just want to keep hearing it over
and over again truly honestly
comforting and enjoyable and interesting
to listen to
amazing um thank you so i'm excited that
you and miranda became fast friends
that's what i've uh gathered from this
discussion um
but what was it like working with her on
this record
um i mean it was great it
she's such a superstar so when we were
recording it didn't take that long
yeah um i showed up with i think six
bottles of liquor just to like make it
so that we weren't nervous
yeah wait what kind of liquor what are
we talking like tequila well she loves
she loves tito's and so i brought her a
handle of tito's
i brought her i was i i was really into
like sake so i brought a bottle of like
sweet sake yeah um and then i brought
her
like i brought like two bottles of
tequila and maybe maybe two handles of
tito
just to get us started you know and then
um she was so funny and so cool and
and like she got real gravely with it it
was it was awesome
we released a little like behind the
scenes video of us and you can see us
just like
dancing and singing and having fun and
um
she's just the coolest and then like
literally like how we shot the music
video was like
us just fooling around and like what
would we do at a wedding you know so
she's really cute and she's just the
sweetest she's so cool
i told i told her that i was pregnant
the day of the music video and
and uh because she she texted me i don't
know if i'll get in trouble for saying
this
she texted me she said all right i'm
making a drink you want one and i said
i'm not drinking
and uh and she knew that i because when
i had had my loss i was on tour with her
and um that she was a really big comfort
to me
yeah and so when she texted me she
texted me i was like i'm not drinking
and she goes
are you she said oh god oh lord
so uh she's just the coolest she's
really
she's just really supportive and i'm
glad that we have a song together and i
hope that she's proud of it
oh yeah well the video is fun the
fashion the hair
you know what was it like for you when
you saw miranda's big 80s hair for the
first time what was your reaction well
they didn't show me a picture of her and
so when we both walked to set
we looked at each other and i had that
big wedding dress on
and she had her bridesmaid dress on with
the big hair and we were like
oh my gosh like can i touch you we just
look
so ridiculous yeah and it was so funny i
think we just laughed
we just kept laughing because i mean
but that's what's fun about like music
videos are
so stressful and it's like okay how do i
look thin
how do i like sing to camera and be the
prettiest that i can be
so i was like why don't we just play
characters so it takes that pressure off
and we can have fun like and now like i
can i'm gonna really remember that
because
i feel like this video is like it's like
my favorite video i've ever done and my
favorite video
to watch because you could tell that i
was really truly enjoying myself
yeah so there's something to be said
about that yeah i know totally
um i know that you're getting married in
real life so
would you incorporate any of these looks
into your real wedding
you know what's funny i felt so
beautiful in that ridiculous wedding
dress
i don't know what it is and and because
daniel my fiance played the groom
in the video we like it like felt like
our wedding day
because we're probably gonna have like a
white trash wedding anyways
um but i i think i'll wear
like a a more subtle gown probably
yeah okay okay so what's one thing that
you do want at your wedding
anything in general that you're like i
need this
you know what i i i'm not crazy i don't
really care about like
seated tables or anything i mean i think
like
if if we could like outline our dream
wedding
my dream wedding i want like carnival
games like a dunk tank
pie eating contest and just food trucks
with like bales of hay
and just a party and a great band that's
sounds good to me yeah and just like
live band karaoke you know
ooh i like that that's fun